[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال
امريكي لروسيا تخفيف العقوبات مقابل
التفاوض للانسحاب من اوكرانيا
اعتبر ان التنسيق الامني مع حكومه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لم يعد قائما اعتبارا
من الان بعد احداث جنين السلطه الفلسطينيه
توقف التنسيق الامني مع اسرائيل وتتوجه
الى الجنايات الدوليه
اي اختلاف او اي خلاف في اي من
امورناني يؤكد توافق كامل بين السودان
واثيوبيا حول سد النهضه
شو عم بعد استعاده حساباتي على فيسبوك
وانستغرام لا ينبغي لماده حاضر حساب رئيس
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
بعد يوم فقط من ارسال الدبابات الى اكياف
تقدم واشنطن اليوم عرضها الاول لموسكو
الذي يتضمن تخفيف العقوبات الغربيه
المفروضه على روسيا مقابل دخول الاخيره في
مفاوضات جاده والانسحاب من اوكرانيا هذا
العرض جاء على لسان مسؤوله امريكيه اما
البنتاجون فكشف عن ان الاحداث بالاشهر
القادمه في اوكرانيا قد تكون حاسمه للحرب
تطورات كذا من طبعا مع اعلان وسائل اعلام
امريكيه عن ان بعد ان يبحث زياره اوروبا
الشهر المقبل بالتزامن مع ذكر الاولى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا ميدانيا في ما يخص المعارك واخر
التطورات على الجبهات الشرقيه منها اعلنها
الجيش الروسيه
تقضي على الدفاعات الاوكرانيه على اكثر من
جبهه سابدا بمبخوت حيث تحاول القوات
الاوكرانيه هنا او عفوا القوات الروسيه
كانت قد حاولت بهذه النقطه تحديدا
بالتطويق المنطقه بعد السيطره
فقامت اذن بتطويق بعد السيطره على فوليدار
قامت القوات الاوكرانيه الروسيه همم تطبيق
من جبهات عده ومحاوله السيطره على هذه
المدينه التي تعتبر مدينه استراتيجيه بهذه
الحرب وهو طبعا ما اثار حفيظه الغرب
الاونه الاخيره وادى الى ارسال دبابات
ومساعدات غربيه الى هذه المنطقه الى باخمه
تحديدا من باخ موت الى دنيا بالدنياسك
ايضا هناك معارك داريه همم تجري بهذه
الاثناء في محيط دونياس حيث تكثف القوات
الروسيه هجماتها وايضا تحاول القوات
الاوكرانيه احراز همم يعني تفوق على الارض
وتقدم على الارض ولكن طبعا كما هو معلوم
القوات الاوكرانيه تتفوق على الروسيه
بعدد الجنود هنا وايضا بالاسلحه والمعدات
الحربيه من انظمه دفاع من طائرات وغيره
بهذه المنطقه هناك معارك ايضا تدور في
مانجا هذه المنطقه التي تعتبر استراتيجيه
هناك همم محاوله للقوات الاوكرانيه باحراس
تقدم فيها وايضا القوات الروسيه هنا تحكم
السيطره على شبهات عدى بهذه المنطقه حيث
هناك يعني معركه حاميه في هذه المناطق
طبعا مشاهدينا بمزازات هذه الصوره هناك
الصوره في زابوريجيا حيث محاوله روسيه
باحكام السيطره على المنطقه كامله وايضا
بحسب مراسلينا هناك هناك محاوله روسيه
لاستحداث نقاط ثابته واستقدام حوالي
40,000 مقاتل لاحراس تقدم بهذه المنطقه
التي تعتبر ايضا استراتيجيه بموازات كل
الصوره على الارض القوات الروسيه والقوات
الاوكرانيه يعني توقع همم ضحايا
باتحدث هنا من الجانبين وايضا هناك خسائر
بالعتاد بالدبابات بالصواريخ وبالانظمه
الدفاع تحاول القوهتين يعني باحداث خسائر
بالغه عند الطرفين اذا هذه هي كانت الصوره
اوكرانيا الميريتانيه طبعا
[موسيقى]
الامدادات العسكريه البريه لتدعيم هجمات
القوات الاوكرانيه قد ترافقها جوا طائرات
مقاتله وقنابل محظوره حيث تدور محادثات
حول نقل طرف ثالث لطائرات اف 16 اي اعاده
بعض الدول تصدير طائراتها الامريكيه الى
كياب للدفاع عن مجالها الجوي شركه لوكيد
مارتن المنتجه لهذا الطراز من الطائرات
ابدت استعدادها لتلبيه الطلب وفقا لصحيفه
فاينل اف 16 او الصقر المقاتل طائره
مقاتله نفاثه احاديه المحرك خفيفه الوزن
ومتعدده المهام ثم مات مشاهدينا كطائره
قنص خفيفه
وتطورت لمقاتله هجوميه دقيقه الاصابه
للاهداف ولديها طبعا قدره كبيره على
المناوره في الساحه تم انتاج حوالي
4540 طائره اف 16 ولم تعد تشتريها القوات
الامريكيه لكن الانتاج مستمر لاغراض
التصدير مناقشات الاف 16 تتزامن مع اقتراح
دوله اوروبيه لم يكشف عن هويتها بعد ارسال
ذخائر عنقوديه لاوكرانيا هذه الذخائر
محرمه دوليا وفقا معاهده امميه وقعتها
معظم الدول الغربيه باستثناء روسيا كما هو
معلوم فهي تنثر مشاهدينا عددا كبيرا من
القنابل الصغيره المتفجره وغالبا طبعا ما
تشكل تهديدا لفتره طويله حتى بعد انتهاء
الاذاعات لكن الدوله المجهوله حتى اللحظه
تشادل بان القنابل العنقضيه اسلحه مشروعه
فاضرار هذه القنابل الجلبيه جانبيه لم تعد
كبيره كما في السابق ويمكن التحكم بها
بشكل كبير وفقا تعبير هذه الدوله المجهوله
وللمفارقه بان شحنه القنابل هي هي الاخرى
بحاجه لضوء اخضر الماني لمشارتها في
الانتاج كما حصل مع دبابات ليوبارت اثنين
[موسيقى]
الدعم الغربي شركه فيه ايطاليا التي تحدثت
وسائل اعلامها عن ان روما سترسل الى
اوكرانيا انظمه دفاعيه مضاده للطائرات
ومسيرات اسرائيليات الصنع كم اشارت الى ان
ايطاليا سترسل قطاع مدفعيه ثقيله ومدرعات
وذخيره الى اوكرانيا
قبل ذلك قال وزير الدوله البريطانيه
لمشتريات الدفاع ان بريطانيا تامل في وصول
دبابات تشالنجر 2 لي اوكرانيا التي تزودها
طبعا لاوكرانيا الى البلاد في نهايه مارس
وقالت بريطانيا انها سترسل 14 دبابه
قتاليه رئيسيه الى جانبي دعم المدفعي
اضافي لاوكرانيا وقال امام البرلمان ردا
على سؤال حول موعد وصول الدبابات الى
اوكرانيا قلى المسؤول بان النيه هي ان
تكون في نهايه مارس طبعا
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من لندن عبرس سكايب
روبرت فوكس الباحث في الشؤون العسكريه
والامنيه استاذ رابورت يعني اليوم الحديث
الاساسي عن اذا ما كانت هذه الاسلحه
الغربيه
تصنع نوع من التوازن من العسكري على الارض
وتغيير بموازين القوى هل باستطاعه سؤال
الرئيسي هل باستطاعه الدول الغربيه ان تمد
اوكرانيا بالذخائر بما ان يعني ان نتحدث
عن طول امد الحرب
نعم نعم
وقطع الغيار والامدادات الاخرى وورش العمل
والمرافق الخاصه بها اذا ما كانت
ستتوجد في اوكرانيا او في بولندا وبعضها
المشاهده العسكريه الامريكيه
ضروريه بالنسبه لان هناك قدر كبير
لابد منها موجود في اوروبا وهذه الدبابات
كلها بحاجه الى صيانه
يمكنها ان تقدم كلها ما تحتاجه هذه
الدبابات انت محققه في ما ذكرته بشان
الذخيره بحيث وهناك ضروري
في ظل القلق المتزايد ويمكن الاستفاده من
القاره الاسيويه وكوريا الجنوبيه يبدو ان
تكون يبدو انها من احد المرشحين لتصبح
موردا اساسيا
وهذا سوف يكون مهما بالنسبه للدبابات
تستهلك بشهر ما تنضجهم ناتو عن سنه
باختصار لو سمحت لانتقل الى موضوع القنابل
العنقديه
فاندام
الخاص بها في الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
كانت غير كافيه وكانوا ينظرون عبر
التحالفات الخاصه بهم هناك رساله واضحه
بانه بصرف النظر عما تسمعونه من ان النيته
حتى اللحظه هو غير مستعد للحرب ولهذا
الامر تم العمل على زياده الانتاج الدفاعي
وهذا يحدث الان في الولايات المتحده وسوف
يحدث في الهند وغيرها
اليوم هناك حديث وتسريبات عن دوله اوروبيه
ستعطي قنابل عنقوديه هذه هذا يعني منافي
للقوانين الدوليه هل ممكن التكهن من هي
هذه الجوله وكيف سيتعاطى المجتمع الدولي
مع هذا الموضوع
ما تتوقع ان تكون رده روسيا
[موسيقى]
جل تايمز حول الاف السته عشر ومن خلال هذه
الطريقه بدات تتوارد الاخبار لان بعد ذلك
همم
الكل يدركه ان الاف 16 كان فقد استخدمت
هذا النوع من القنابل العنقوديه في السابق
لكن هذا يوحي
مدى النجاح حمله المعلومات الروسيه همم
المتعلقه باطراف ثالثه في في الخليج وفي
افريقيا لانه من الذي سوف يقوم بتزويد هذه
القنابل العنقوديه
فهد
يرغب بهذا الاسم بشده لكن في البدايه لابد
لنا ان ندرك ان
هذه القنابل سوف تكون ذات قدر رفع كبيره
وفعاله اذا ما اطلقت بالصواريخ ذات مدى
قصيره
المملكه المتحده قدمت صواريخ برنستون التي
تطلق من من هيليكوبتر او من بعض الطريق
الطائرات المروحيه الاخرى التي يمكنه ان
تحلق على مسافه منفضه هو تحمل على متنها
600 طن وتسير لمسافه كبيره علينا ان ننظر
ما قد يحدث بالنسبه
للي همم الدول الاوروبيه المزوده للدخائر
وهنا نشير الى بريطانيا وفرنسا وايطاليا
انا لست متاكده اذا ما سوف
تكون رخيصه سوف يتم تقديمها قد تكون مخطئا
في هذا الخصوص
وكما تعلمون بانه البعض منها كان قد
استخدم في في اليمن
من خلال الحلف الذي تقوده السعوديه روسيا
سوف تصدر ردود افعال من خلال البروبوغندا
الخاصه بها لكنني اعتقدوا بان الامر قد
وضع سعرا عليه وقد تم تاكيده في ميدان
المعركه سلفا
الاخر تشهد المعركه الروسيه الاوكرانيه
الغرب دبابات واليات عسكريه متطوره قد
يبقى الصراع بين موسكو وكيف دون حسن في ظل
محاولات كل طرف تحقيق اختراق على حساب
نقاط ضعف الاخر وفق خبراء عسكريين
معركه عسكريه مستعره وتصميم روسيه على
تحقيق اهدافها في الجانب الاخر من
المواجهه دعم غربي متواصل لاوكرانيا
التدفق للاسلحه الغربيه لا يتوقف لكنه لا
يكفي لترجيح كافتكيف في ميزان المعركه مع
موسكو
وفقا لخبراء عسكريين تمتلك القوه
الاوكرانيه معدات واليات عسكريه تتميز
بالتنوع والتطور الى جانبه وفره في خزائن
سلاح مدعوم من الغرب لكنها تفتقر الى
انظمه صيانه وامداد تواكب هذا الدعم ما
يجعل هذه الترسانه دوما في وضعيه عدم
استغلال امثال لغياب القدره على تصنيع
الذخيره الخاصه بها
تشير التقارير العسكريه الى زياده في
عمليه التدريب للجنود الاوكرانيين من
الغرب مصحوبه بحملات تعبئه واسعه للمجندين
لكنها لا تتمتع بوجود قاده من ذوي الخبرات
التي لا يمكن الحصول عليها الا بمرور
الزمن والتجارب
ليست اوكرانيا وحدها التي تمتلك نقاط ضعف
روسيا تمر بمشكلات تتعلق بقدرته بعض
الاسلحه السوفيتيه الى جانب حشد وتجنيد
الافراد لكنها في الوقت ذاته تمتلك سلاحا
جويا وبحريا فائق القدره الى جانب فريق
انتاج وتصنيع واصلاح للمركبات العسكريه
وقد في الدبابات والمدفعيه ووفقا للخبراء
العسكريين فان ميزان التكافؤ بين روسيا
واوكرانيا يفتقر للتوازن حتى اللحظه
الحاليه لم تتمكن اوكرانيا من الانتقال من
حاله الدفاع العسكري الى الهجوم فما زالت
تعاني من خلل في اساسيات تكوين وحدات
الهجوميه قادره على تحقيق نصر في عمليه
عسكريه قد يطول امادوها
علي السمان العربيه
ايضا اذا اعلن وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
فرط قيود على منح التاشيرات ل 531 من
العسكريين الروس كما صنفط وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه كجماعه
اجراميه دوليه وفرضت عقوبات على افراد
مرتبطين بالمجموعه العسكريه الروسيه وفرضت
الخزانه الامريكيه عقوبات على شركات اصلاح
السفن في روسيا كما شملت العقوبات الجديده
التي فرضتها الخزانه الامريكيه نائب رئيس
الوزراء الروسي ورئيس جمهوريه تتارستان
الروسيه
وقبل حديث عن مرتزقه فاجنر الذين ومعظمهم
مودانين وافقوا على اطلاق سراح مشروط
بخدمه على الجبهات الاماميه والالتزام
طبعا بقواعد قد يجرهم كسرها الى حبل
المشنقه فهؤلاء العناصر الذين يعضا اليهم
التقدم الروسي في سوليدار وباخمود يخضعون
لقواعد صارمه ربما تتفاوت مع الجنود الروس
المجموعات المهاجمه لا تنسحب بدون امر
وتنطبق عقوبه الاعدام فورا على اي شخص اا
ينسحب من غير تصريح او من دون التعرض
لاصابه مقاتله غالبا ما يتركون شرحاهم
خلفهم لساعات حيث يمنع المشاه الهجوميين
من حمل الجارحه من ساحه المعركه بمفردهم
نظرا الى ان مهمتهم الرئيسيه تتمثل في
مواصله الهجوم حتى يتم تحقيق الهدف وفي
حال فش هجوم لا يسمح لهم بالتراجع الا في
الليل فاجنر تنشر قواتها في مجموعات
متنقله من حوالي 12 شخصا او اقل تكتيك
يرجح خبراء مشاهدين ان تقلده القوات
الروسيه المدنون يشكلون الموجه الاولى اي
الهجوم ويتكبدون 80% من الخسائر يتبع ذلك
مقاتلون اكثر خبره مسلحين بمعدلات التصوير
الحراري ومعدات الرؤيه الليليه هذا واظهرت
تحليلات لصور اقمار صناعيه ومقاطع فيديو
نشرتها نيويورك تايمز توسع المدافن التي
تستخدمها مجموعه فاجنر وبسرعه وقدرت بنحو
سبعه اضعاف خلالها شهرين
[موسيقى]
الحديث اكثر عن التطورات على الارض ياض
طمني
مساء الخير ليال يعني هنالك تحديث اولا
بخصوص عمليه القصف التي تمت اليوم للاراضي
الاوكرانيه اعلنت هيئه الطوارئ الحكوميه
عن 11 قتيلا و11 جريحا في 11 منطقه في
يعني الولايات الاوكرانيه ايضا فاليري ذا
لوجن القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه نشر تحديثا حول عدد الصواريخ
التي تم بها استهداف الاراضي الاوكرانيه
قال ان هنالك 55 صاروخا تم بهم استهداف
الاراضي الاوكرانيه استطاعت القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ان تسقط منهم سبعه واربعين
صاروخان هذا فيما يخص عمليات القصف التي
تمت اليوم طبعا ايضا هنالك اضرار في
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه خاصه في نمره
بتروسكو اديسا اما ولايه فقط اعلنت ان
الضرب الصاروخيه التي استهدفت احد من
شائعات الطاقه ان الاثر لم يكن كبيرا
ويبقى الوضع كما كان عليه قبل هذه الضربه
ويستمر الامداد طبعا مع عمليات قطاعات
مبرمجه هذا من جانب طبعا في جبهات القتال
تحديدا قالت القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه او
هيئه الاركان المشتركه في بيانها المسائل
قالت ان القوات الروسيه ركزت الضرباتها
وركزت ايضا عمليات الهجوم في منطقه باخموت
في الدونيسك تحديدا وايضا في منطقه صفاتهم
في لوغاز ولكن دون نجاح يذكر كما انها
قالت انه هنالك عمليات قصف مدينه خرسون
بيراجمات الصواريخ طبعا هنا نتحدث وكذلك
في زبرج كان هنالك محاولات للتقدم لكنها
بعد الفشل وقالت ان القوات الاوكرانيه
مطمئن على وضع الدفاع في مدينه باكو
تحديدا ولا توجد ايميه في الوقت الحالي
للانسحاب من هذه المدينه او تسليمها
للقوات الروسيه ايضا الرئيس
عقد اجتماع لهيئه الاركان المشتركه
والاجتماع تناول قضايا هامه جدا اولها
طبعا عمليه تسليم الدبابات لاوكرانيا وهنا
لا بد ان اشير الى ان الجانب الالماني قال
انه سوف يبدا بتسليم الدبابات في اول
ابريل وكذلك بولندا قالت ان عده اسابيع
تفصيلها من تسليم هذه الدبابات للجانب
الاوكراني كذلك اجتماع هيئه الاركان تحدث
عن عمليات التدريب والاسراع في عمليات
التدريب للجيش الاوكراني على الاسلحه
الغربيه الجديده وايضا عمليات الصيانه وما
الى ذلك وطبعا ايضا استمع الى القاده
الميدانيين للعمليات العسكريه في جميع
الاقاليم الان شكرا لك حذيفه
تحت شعار محاربه نظام بوتين والشر والفساد
اختار فيلقروسي المقاتلون روز للجبهه
الاوكرانيه من من القتال حريه روسيا يرفض
وصمه بالخيانه
لمقاتلاته الى جان المقاتلات الى جانب
القوات الاوكرانيه وفقه صحيفه
تتشكل مع بدء العمليه الروسيه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا ويضم مئات الروس رغم تكتمهم عن
العدد الدقيق ثم نشرهم بعد التدريب لشهرين
فيهم بس في مايو الماضي في ما يقاتل بعض
الجنود حاليا في باخمه تحت قياده القوات
الاوكرانيه وهم يشاركون عاده في اطلاق
المدفعيه المجندون خضعوا لمقابلات عده
وشولات من الاختبارات النفسيه وحتى جهاز
كشف الكذب للتاكد من ولائهم وفقه الضابط
المسؤول عنهم ويصف خبراء عسكريون اهميه
مساهمه الفيلق الروسيه في المجهود الحربي
بالرمزيه السياسيه اكثر منها الع هي نظرا
الى قله عددهم
[موسيقى]
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
نقابه المحامين اللبنانيين تصفوا قرار
النائب العام باطلاق سراح الموقوفين بقضيه
المرفا غير قانوني
[موسيقى]
القسطره القلبيه العلاجيه
وجراحات القلب على مداري 24 ساعه
بمستشفيات المواساه
المواساه خبره تنبض بالثقه
[موسيقى]
نبض الصور
في هذه الاوقات على الشاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
العربيه
وعالميا في زمن الاحداث والتغيرات
المفاجئه التي يشهدها العالم
العربيه
خدمه البث المباشر وعرض القصص والبرامج
حسب الطلب
تفكير بما قد فاتك من اخبار مع تسليط
الضوء على الاخبار التي تحدث بالقرب منك
ابدا الان لتكون على تواصل مع كل ما هو
جديد مصدرك الاول للمعلومات العربيه دوت
نت
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال المتحدث باسم
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه نبيل ابو ردينه ان
الحكومه قررت وقفه تنسيق الامني مع
اسرائيل وتوجه بملف جنين للجنائي جنائيه
الدوليه وذلك بعد الاحداث الداميه التي
شهدها مخيم جنين صباح اليوم الخميس
قررت القياده الفلسطينيه في اجتماعه
الطارئ اليوم ما يلي
في ضوء العدوان المتكرر على ابناء الشعبنا
والضرب بعرض الحائط للاتفاقات الموقعه بما
فيها الامنيه نعتبر ان التنسيق الامني مع
حكومه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لم يعد قائما
اعتبارا من الان
ان التنسيق الامني ما حكومه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لم يعد قائما اعتبارا من الان
هذا وقالت مصادر للعربيه ان المسؤولين
امنيين مصريين على تواصل مع اسرائيل لوقف
التصعيد بالاراضي الفلسطينيه وكانت وكاله
الانباء الفلسطينيه افادت باندلاع مواجهات
بين مواطنين وقوات اسرائيليه في عده مدن
بالضفه الغربيه واشاره الوكاله الى اضراب
شامل في الضفه الغربيه والقدس حدادا على
ارواح قتل الهجوم الاسرائيليه على مدينه
جنين ومخيمها والذين وصل عددهم الى تسعه
قتلى حسب ما اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
ماذا فعل طبعا الرئاسه الفلسطينيه الى
الدعوه للتحرك دوليه
[موسيقى]
هذول اجم الشارع العنبر يا شباب هسه
[تصفيق]
انه والسنكار المملكه الشديدين لقرحان
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لمدينه ومخيم
جنين ما ادى الى سقوط عدد من الضحايا
واصابه اخرين واكدت السعوديه رفضها التام
لما تقوم به قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من
انتهاكات خطيره للقانون الدولي مشدده على
مطالباتها للمجتمع الدولي بالاطلاعي
بمسؤوليته لانهاء الاحتلال ووقف التصعيد
والاعتداءات الاسرائيليه وتوفير الحمايه
اللازمه للمدنيين
الحديث اكثر عن التطورات على الارض هناك
ينضم الينا من القدس زياد حلب مراسل
العربيه زياد كيف هي الصوره الان بعد
التصعيد الذي شاهدناه في الساعات الماضيه
على طرفي الخط الاخضر باعتقاده لمزيد ربما
من التصعيد
وربما الساعه المقبله عند السابعه جرينتش
التاسعه مساء بتوقيت القدس المحتله همم
ربما يمكن ان تكون هناك عمليه اطلاق
صواريخ من الجهاد الاسلامي لا يستبعد ذلك
تجاه مستوطنات غلاف قطاع غزه ردا على ما
يصفه الفلسطينيون عمليا بالمجزره في مخيم
جنين شمالي الضفه الغربيه
المحتله همم انا فقدته الاتصال ساواصل الى
حين يعني يتم ايقافه همم وبالتالي كان
هناك مشاورات امنيه اجراها نتنياهو مع
وزير الدفاع والقاده الامنيين
وكذا ايضا همم رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي
اجرى مشاورات هو الاخر همم تم اقرار خطط
عسكريه لاستهداف مواقع في قطاع غزه في حال
تم اطلاق صواريخ وفقه ما تدعي صادر همم في
همم اسرائيل همم عمليه هناك خشيه من ان
يكون هناك تصعيد نوعي في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله وفي القدس الشرقيه ايضا خاصه غدا
همم مع صلاه الجمعه عمليه هذا ايضا عين
الاسرائيليين تتجه الى ذلك ال همم الموعد
خشيه من اندلاع مواجهات في نقاط التماس
وايضا عمليات اطلاق نار على الحواجز
الاسرائيليه عمليه بالنسبه لقوات
الاسرائيليه هناك حاله تاهل قسوه تم نشر
بطاريات القبه الحديديه في المنطقه
الجنوبيه ويلاحظ حال الاستنفار قسوه عمليه
على جبهه قطاع غزه الان عاده الاتصال همم
شاهدنا عكس على الارض هل همم هل يمكن يعني
الحديث عن سياسات الحكومه اليمنيه
ففي الاشهر المقبله او في الفتره المقبله
بيضل كل التصعيد الحاصل
بدون مشاكل بان نتنياهو يبدو اسيرا بشكل
او باخر ل همم قوى اكتر تطرفا منه في
الحكومه نقصد بذلك على وجه تحديد وفقه
المراقبين همم كل من اسمه كلا من سمودردش
همم الوزير مودريج والوزير عمليا همام من
يديران الدفه في اتجاه التصعيد اكثر همم
في همم العلاقه المتفجره بطبيعتها
الفلسطينيه همم وبالتالي هذا الامر همم
سنشهد المزيد من التصعيد نتنياهو اليوم
طلب ان يحاول الجيش الاسرائيلي تخفيفه
لاقتحامات في الايام المقبله السبب بسيط
وواضح همم وهو انكن سيصل نهايه الشهر الى
اسرائيل وسيزور رام الله اسرائيل لا تريد
ان يصل وقد فجر الوضع تماما ان كان في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله او في قطاع غزه
اخشى انني فقط الاتصال مجددا شكرا لك حلبي
مراسل العربيه على هذه الرساله من القدس
قوه اسرائيليه خاصه تدخل بزي مدني مخيم
جنين عند السابعه صباحا بعد انكشاف امرها
وتعرضها لاطلاق النار من مسلحين فلسطينيين
اجتاح الجيش الاسرائيلي المخيم واوقع عددا
من الضحايا بين قتيل وجريح
بعد ساعه على انسحاب الجيش الاسرائيلي من
مخيم جنين بقيت دخان المتساعد من هذا
المنزل شاهد على اربع ساعات من الاشتباكات
والانفجارات التي عمت احياء مخيم جنين
خلال اجتياح الجيش الاسرائيلي للمخيم
ومحاصره المنازل تفضلوا هون في الدور اللي
هون في الظهر
وبلش اطلاق انا ارجع على البيت
احتجز في البيت اللي تحت هذا البيت
احتجزوا فيه اصحاب البيت
وقعدوه مسكره علوم البيت وبلشوا من البيت
نفسه يضربوا ونرجع البيت هذا صواريخ
الجيش الاسرائيلي فيما لا يزال العشرات
يتلقون العلاج في المشاكل الفلسطينيه وصفت
جراحه اربعه منهم بالحرجه
لتتصدر المشهد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه في
عمليه وصفت بالاعنه في منذ تولي الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده زمام الحكم في
اسرائيل ما ينظر بتصعيد خطير على صعيد
الصراع الاسرائيليه الفلسطينيه
في المنطقه من مدخل مخيم جنين خالد القاسم
العربيه
[موسيقى]
التحقيق في انفجار مرفا بيروت يتعرقل اكثر
مع خلاف المشتعل بين القاضيين في النائب
العام التمييزي غسان عويدات وجهتهامات الى
القاضي طارق البيطار الذي يراس التحقيقات
وامر بالافراج عن جميع من جرى اعتقاله
وساق اتهامات للبيطار باغتصاب السلطه مع
اصدار قرار بمنعه من السفر برا وشرا وبحرا
بدورها قالت نقابه المحامين اللبنانيين ان
قرار النائب العام باطلاق سراح الموقوفين
بقضيه المرفا غير قانونيه مضيفه اي
النقابه انه على القضاه احترام قسمهم
لتفادي التحقيق الدولي في قضيه وفيما وصف
بالطعنه بظهر القضاء نظما نواب مستقلون
ومعارضون واهالي ضحايا انفجار المرفا
اعتصاما امام قصر العدل وهي ذلك مع اجتماع
لمجلس القضاء الاعلى لبحث التطورات
اليوم مش بس انقلاب على الحقيقه والعداله
اللي عملته اليوم انقلاب على المؤسسات
انقلاب على الديمقراطيه انقلاب على
الحريات ومحاوله فرد على اللبنانيين نظام
بوليسي جديد شغلتنا نحمي القضاء من
التدخلات السياسيه ومن قضاه السلطه
العربيه ناهد يعني هناك شقين من هذا
السؤال الشرق الاول على ما يبدو بدات
اقفال الطرقات هل هناك اي خريطه لاطفال
الطرقات في الساعات المقبله والشقه
الثانيه التطورات اليوم مع اتهامات التي
قيلت لان المدعي العام التمييزه بانه نفذ
اوامر حزب الله باطلاق سراح كل الموقفين
بملابس انفجار
نعم ليال بالنسبه للشق الاول في هذه
الاثناء ليس هناك من قطع من طرقات كنا
شاهدنا خلال النهار ومنذ يوم امس يعني قطع
لطرقات ولكن باوقات متقطعه يعني مده قصيره
من الزمن ان كان هي ليست فقط بسبب ما حصل
في ملف المرفق ولكن ايضا بالنسبه للوضع
الاقتصادي خصوصا ان الدولار سجل رقم
قياسيا جديدا وهو 61000 ليره للدولار وهو
اعلى رقم قياسي لانهيار العمله في هذه
اللحظات ليس هناك قطع طرقات وليست هناك
خريطه في الساعات المقبله يعني يكون هذا
الموضوع عاده عفويا ليس هناك من دعوات
لقطع طرقات اما بالنسبه
وهذه الاتهامات همم كانت يعني واضحه اليوم
من التجمعات التي حصلت امام قصر العدل ان
كان من النواب وان كان من اهل الضحايا او
من المواطنين الذين حضروا كانت هناك
هتافات مندده بحزب الله كانت
مطالبه للتخلص من سيطره ايران على لبنان
الواضحه في هذا الملف سابقا عندما هدد
المسؤول همم وفيق السفر مسؤول في حزب الله
بقبع البيطار وهدد بتكسير قصر العدل لم
يتحدث او ينطق او او يقول اي احد من
القضاه شيئا او يرد على هذا الكلام وهذا
الامر المستعجل اذ انه عندما هدد بتكسير
قصر العدل لا القاضي غسان عويدات ولا احد
من القضاه تجرا على الرد ولكن اليوم عندما
تظهر هؤلاء من اجل الحقيقه والعداله عملوا
بهذه الطريقه التي عمل بها اليوم اليوم
هناك كان سبب حصلت سابقه وهي التعدي على
نواب يعني شاهدنا ضرب ثلاثه نواب خلال
اجتماعي بوزير العدل وهو ما لم يكن يحصل
وان برره وزير العدل بعدها بانه بسبب همم
تخطي او تتفوه بالفاظ نابيه من قبل بعض
النواب الا انه تم الاعتداء عليهم من قبل
مرافقيه كما اكتمل الاعتداء على عدد من
المواط خارج قصر العدل الذين بعدها قاموا
بخلع البوابه الحديديه رفضا لما كان يحصل
القاضي عويدات في دردشه مع الصحفيين بعدها
برر ان ما قام به من اطلاق سراح اولا قال
بانه لم ينفذ قرار قضيبي صار اولا لانه لا
يعتبره قانوني بامكان بالنسبه لاخلاء
صراحه الموقوفين الخمسه الذين طلب باخلاقي
صراحهم وانه في حال نفذ ذلك فهذا يعني
اعتراف بقراره وما لن يحصل وانه قام
باطلاق سراح جميع الموقوفين لان همم لانهم
نفذوا مده توقفهم الاحتياطي وقال سنستانف
ملف تحقيق المرفا عندما نصحح الخطا الكبير
وهنا يقصد القاضي بيطار وقال ايضا انه ان
كان اي مرجع قانوني قال بان هناك ذره
قانونيه في قرار القاضي بتغير عندها همم
تتراجع عن قراره ولكن طبعا هذا لم يحصل
لانه يعترف بانه ليس قانونيا ولكن الشيء
الكبير يمكن القول بانه حصل اليوم ان ضغط
الشارع تمكن من الغاء جلسه مجلس القضاء
الاعلى التي كانت مقرره اليوم والتي بحسب
المعلومات كان هناك اتجاه ونيه خلال هذا
الاجتماع الى همم تعيين قادم رديف عن
القاضي بيطار ولكن القضاه رفضوا الاجتماع
وقالوا اننا لن نجتمع تحت ضغط الشارع وانه
ورفض ايضا مواكبه النواب الى هذا همم
معتمرين انه تدخل سافر بالقضاء من قبل
نواب حسب مرجع قضائي
للعربيه وبالتالي لم يعقد هذا الاجتماع
ولم يحدد موعد اخر لعقد هكذا اجتماع نهد
شكرا لك على هذه الرساله حدثتنا من بيروت
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان لا خلاف بين السودان
واثيوبيا حول سد النهضه وان البلدين
متوافقين ومتفقين حول كافه قضايا السد
واوضح البرهان خلال الجلسه او جلسه
المباحثات المشتركه مع رئيس الوزراء
الاثيوبيه ابي احمد الوثائق والاليات
الفنيه والحوار تمثل مرجعيه الاساسيه فيما
يتعلق بقضيه حدود بين البلدين من جانبه
قال ابي احمد ان سد النهضه لن يسبب اي ضرر
للسودان وسيعود عليه بالمنفعه في مجال
الكهرباء مبينا قضيه الحدود بين البلدين
بانها قديمه ويجب الرجوع الى الوثائق لحل
لها داعيا السودان لتقديم اثيوبيا للعرب
والافارقه بحكم موقعه التاريخيه
نحن دوما نسعى لان تظل اثيوبيا موحده
اثيوبيا قويه وهم يبادلون هذا الشعور ايضا
يريدون ان يرص ودان ايضا واحدا قويا يعبر
الى مصاف او الى تحقيق امنيات شعبه نحنا
بنحييهم ان احنا اتفقنا في كل الامور كلما
نقشناه من امر لم نجد اي اختلاف او اي
اختلاف في اي من امورنا وهي كلها نريدها
ان تصب في مصلحه الشعبين لتقويه هذه
العلاقه بين الدولتين الجارتين الشقيقتين
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من القاهره الدكتور
ضياء الدين القوصي مستشار وزير الري
الاسبق وخبير المياه الدولي دكتور يعني من
المعلوم ان ال ال نقطه الخلافه الاساسيه
بين كل من السودان اثيوبيا ومصر كانت
عمليه الجدول الزمني والقانوني والدستوري
بموضوع ملء السد اليوم اذا السودان قالت
ان لا مشكله بينها وبين اثيوبيا ما هو
الحل الذي ممكن ان يكون قد توصلوا اليه
وكيف سينعكس ذلك على القاهره وموقف
القاهره من هذا الموضوع
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم شكرا على استضافه
الكريمه
واتصور نحن
يجب ان نكون متفائلين
عندما نسمع هذا الكلام لانه
بالقطع ما قاله السيد رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني يلوم عن اتفاق شبه تام على جميع
النقاط وهذا الاتفاق كما هو والد بين مصر
والسودان لفتره طويله قد تصل الى 10 سنوات
الان اااه
يبدو انه
يلزم
بشكل ابو اخر ان يكون هناك اتفاق تام بين
الدول الثلاثه على اساس انه الدول
المتشطيه على النيل الازرق وهذا الاتفاق
التام يكون فيه الاولويه
لملئ الخزان وملئ الخزان في ظروف مختلفه
ربنا اكرم الجميع بانه سنوات الثلاث
الماضيه كانت في عظام مرتفع فلم نحس فيها
بالمال الاول والثاني والثالث الحقيقه
بشكل او باخر وايضا كان سبب لم تتمكن من
من حجز الكميات التي كانت تبغي حجزاها
الناحيه الثانيه اللي هي تشغيل
يعني هنا
بخلاف الاساسي بين القاهره والسودان
واثيوبيا كان موضوع الاتفاق الثلاثي الذي
يضمن حقوق السودان ومصر بتدفق مياه انها
اليوم على ما يبدو هناك اتفاق سوداني
اثيوبيا اين القاهره من هذا الموضوع
والاهلي القاهره هي الغائب الحاضر في هذه
العمليه
والجائز السودان يعلم جيدا ما هو الموقف
القاهره في الموضوع زي ما انا باقول انه
لازم يكون في اتفاق وعلى على الاداره
والتشغيل ولازم يكون في اتفاق على على فضل
المنازعات ايضا هذه
الصوره واضحه جدا بين مصر والسودان ولها
اظن ان هناك خلاف عليها ثم ان مصر
والسودان هم الاثنين وقائع ولا اتفاقيه
مياه النيل واتفاقيه من النيل تدعوا
بصراحه ووضوح شديدين الى ان اي امر يتعلق
بمياه النيل و و و و و و و و و
دول حض النيل بشكل عام يجب ان يكون هناك
اي نوع من انواع الخلافات وان مصر
والسودان تتقدم الى هذه المفاوضات بصوت
واحد وبراي واحد وبالتفاق كامل بين
الطرفين دكتور ضياء يعني من المعلوم ان
يبقى السوداني يستفيد كثيرا بموضوع توليد
الكهرباء من الجانب الاثيوبي هل ممكن ان
تكون هذه الحاجه اليوم ان تدفع السوداني
يعني لتفريض باي من الشروط التي وضعتها
القاهره في المرحله الماضيه باختصار لو
سمحت
الاستفاده بالكهرباء والاستفاده بالكهرباء
يعني واحده من
المزايا التي ستتمتع بها السودان اذا كان
هناك مجال الاستفاده منها لكن هناك هناك
هناك عيوب شديده جدا في همم في سد وفي وفي
قد يضر بالسودان ضرر واهم هذا واهم هذه
الازرار اللي هي امان سد نفسه لان السد
نفسه قد يكون عطله في اكثر من الاوقات
انهيار لاي سبب من الاسباب وفي هذه الحاله
ستغرق همم مدن كثيره في في في في جمهوريه
السودان الديمقراطيه
وستقبع تحت المياه همم يعني ربنا يكفينا
شرها
هدفي حال عدم التنسيق بين الجانبين دكتور
ضياء يعني بانتظار الموقف الرسمي المصري
من هذا الاتفاق شكرا لك دكتور ضياء الدين
القاسم مستشار وزير الري الاسبق وخبير
المياه الدولي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد محاكمه وصوريه لا ترقى
للمعاير الدوليه
الى اعدامات علنيه او خلف الابواب المنفضه
هذه الاحكام بالشنق على خلفيه تهم دون
مسوغ قانوني وغياب كامل
في ما بينهم لا يقل عن 17 حكما بالاعدام
بعضها من المحكمه العليا الايرانيه وقد
نقد في النقد في الاستئناف سلفات الملقب
بقاضي الموت او قاضي المشانق مدرج على
لائحه العقوبات الامريكيه من عام 2019
فيما القضاه السته الاخرون ليس خاضعين
لهذه العقوبه
[موسيقى]
عقوبات الغربيه متواصله على على ايران من
جهه ومن جهه اخرى
الى ادنى مستوياتها مع قمع السلطات
الايرانيه للمتظاهرين والاعدامات وبيعها
مسيرات
الدول الغربيه محدوده لمنع ايران من توزيع
برنامجها النووي ومحاوله انقاذ الاتفاق
النووي المواقع عام 2015
جميع السبل الدبلوماسيه مع طهران هنا
مسؤول امريكي كبيره اكد معرفه بلاده
باتباع ايران مسار ثابتا للتقدم ببرنامجها
النووي لكنه لا فتى ايضا الا ان التعامل
مع المازق الدبلوماسيه الحالي افضل بكثير
من اي بدائل اخرى وتشمل خيارات الاخرى
السعي الى صفقه محدوده اكثر او عمل عسكري
او العوده الى استراتيجيه الضغط الاقصى
التي اتبعها الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق
دونالد ترامب الاتفاق حاليا في حاله تجمل
اي التزام واشنطن وطهران بالوضع الراهن
بلا اتفاق ولا اسماء دون تجاوز اي خطوط
حمراء قد تؤدي لتصعيد وضع يصفه خبراء بغير
المستدادات
[موسيقى]
اكدت قائد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في
مقابله خاصه مع العربيه عن اثنا عشر الف
مقاتل من جيش النظام السوري ينتشرون في
مناطق العمليات العسكريه التركيه المتوقع
طلبا من النظام
السوري لاي عمليه عسكريه تركيه محتمله ولم
يرد عليها
التواصلنا مستمر مع النظام السوري في
الملفات الامنيه والعسكريه لان الاقاليم
التي تنوي تركي استهدافها يتواجد بها نحو
12000 عنصر من قوات النظام السوري ويوجد
تنسيق بيننا طلبنا منهم التصدي لاي هجوم
تركي لكن النظام السوري لم يرد علينا حتى
الان بشان مواجهه الاحتلال التركي وهذا
واجبهم
يعني
الاطراف
استنتجنا بعد تقييم الاوضاع ان تركيا تريد
شنه هجوم بري على مناطقنا قبل الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والهجوم الذي سيركزون عليه سيكون
في كوباني
ونتوقع ان تفضي المحادثات الجاريه حاليا
بين الروس والاتراك والنظام السوري الى
مساومه اوصفقه بشان شني عمليه في كوباني
القضائيه في بغداد احكاما بالاعدام بحق 14
مدانا
بمجزره او 14 مدن بمجزره معسكر سبايكر
شمال بغداد خلال هجوم لتنظيم داعش سيف
العام 2014 رجاء الاعلام بعد ما اصدرت
المحكمه الجنائيه المركزيه في بغداد حكما
باعدام 14 ارهابيا بعد قتلهم اكثر من 1700
شخص من طلاب القاعده العسكريه لدوافع
ارهابيه في محافظه صلاح الدين
كشفت وزاره الموارد المائيه العراقيه ان
وفدا فنيا سيلتقي الجانب التركي مطلع
الشهر المقبل لبحث حصص العراق المائيه
وقال مستشار وزير الموارد المائيه
العراقيه ان الكميات المائيه الحاليه لا
تسود حاجه العراق الفعليه مؤكدا ان بلاده
تريد من تركيا زياده الاطلاقات المائيه من
2005 الى 500 متر مكعب في الثانيه بحوض
الفرات
[موسيقى]
كشفت وكاله رويترز نقل عن مصادر ان الرئيس
الامريكي بدا في حشد المتبرعين استعدادا
لاطلاق حملاته الانتخابيه خلال اسابيع حيث
من المتوقع ان يعلم عن ترشحه لولايه
الثانيه خلال الاسابيع المقبله بعد القاء
خطاب حاله الاتحاد في السابع فبراير وبحسب
المصادر فان لجنه الوطنيه الديمقراطيه وهي
ذراع الاداره وجمع التمويل للحزب
الديمقراطي ستسعى لجمع تبرعات تتجاوز
الملياردو
بعدما افرجت شركه ماته عن حسابات الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب على فيسبوك
وانستقرام على هذا علقت ترامب على هذا
الاعلان بعد حظر استمر لعامين وقال مانع
رئيس الامريكي من استخدام فيسبوك لا ينبغي
ان يحصل مجددا وقال على موقعه تروس سوشل
بان فيسبوك الذي خسر مليارات الدولارات من
قيمته منذ حظر الرئيس المفضل الذي هو انا
اعلن للتوا انه سيعيد تفعيل حسابي الى
موقع فيسبوك وانستغرام لتواصل الاجتماعي
قريبا فيما قال رئيس ما تلا الشؤون
العالميه في بيان رسمي ان الجمهوريه يجب
ان يكون قادرا على سماع ما يقوله سياسي
[موسيقى]
حسابات ترامب المعلقه على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تعود اليه واحده تلو الاخرى قبل
ايام من انطلاق اول فعاليه انتخابيه له من
مدينه كولومبيا في ولايه ساسكر العراق
[موسيقى]
عوده الحسابات ستمكن ترامب من استخدامها
لتمويل حملته الانتخابيه والتواصل مع
قاعدته المخلصه التي بقيت معه واعلنت ولا
اهتم له
فورمات كويس
السابق ترامب يريد اعاده تنشيط حسابات على
فيسبوك او انستغرام او تويتر لانه يمتلك
شركه تواصل اجتماعي خاصه بها وهي تروث
سوشيلا لذلك فهو لا يريد بالضروره ان يقود
المتابعين الى النايل سات اخرى وبالتالي
مساعده الاخرين على كسب المال متابعوا
ترامب على الفيسبوك ووصلوا الى 34 مليون
متابعا اما انستغرام فالرقم متعدى 23
مليون
صادر عن شركه متى الملكه لفيسبوك
وانستجرام تحدثت عن الحاجه الى ضمان حريه
التعبير وتبادل الافكار وان قرار التعليق
جاء في ظروف اضطراريه والظرف الاضطراري
واحداث السادس من يناير حيث اتهم الرئيس
ترامب بتحريضه مؤيديه على مهاجمه مبنى
الكابيتال امر شكل صدمه للام ومنذ ذلك
الوقت وحسابات الرئيس ترامب معلقه ولم
يكتب اي شيء حتى الان منذ السادس من يناير
اما ترامب فقال لا ينبغي منع اي رئيس
مجددا من استخدام وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وعبر حسابه في تروس سوشيال قال ان فيسبوك
الذي خسر مليارات الدولارات من قيمته منذ
حظر رئيسكم المفضل الذي هو انا والكلام
لترامب اعلن للتو انه سيعيد تفعيله حسابي
ناديه البلبيسي العربي وعشان
[موسيقى]
حركات السيارات وتجول السكان بحذر في
الارصفه المغطاه بثلوج بعدما اجتاحت عاصفه
ثلجيه العاصمه الكوريه الجنوبيه سيال
والمناطق المجاوره لها
[موسيقى]
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العناوين
بعد يوم من ارسال الدبابات امريكيه لروسيا
تخفيف العقوبات مقابل التفاوض للانسحاب من
اوكرانيا
مع حكومه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لم يعد
قائما اعتبارا
جنين السلطه الفلسطينيه توقف تنسيق لاني
مع اسرائيل وتتوجه الى الجنايات الدوليه
لم نجد اي اختلاف او اي خلاف
[موسيقى]
احمد البرهاني يؤكد توافق كامل بين
السودان واثيوبيا حول سد النهضه
ترامب بعد استعاده حساباته على فيسبوك
وانستغرام لا ينبغي لما تحضر حساب رئيس
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله الان الى 360 مع
الزميله راويه واعود والقاكم الاحد ان شاء
الله اليك راويه ماذا لديك الليله اهلا بك
ليال سنتحدث عن سيناريوهات الرد الروسي
على تزويد كاف بالدبابات
حرب القضاء في لبنان مشتعله وايضا
الانتخابات التركيه حاضره معنا